the guy who isn't going to be the
autocrat in Washington President Donald
Trump wants to number one bring back
illegal torture techniques and number
two bring them back by executive order
the mechanism that he was slamming
President Obama for using to get things
done this is yet another one of Donald
Trump's new executive orders this one is
called detention and interrogation of
enemy combatants it would lift bans on
CIA oversee black site prisons used for
torture President Obama shut those down
they were hugely hugely damaging to the
image of the United States abroad the
executive order would lift other
restrictions in terms of how detainees
can be treated it would reverse
President Obama's directive to give the
Red Cross access to detainees to see how
they're being treated and what their
health status is it would expand the use
of Gitmo which should have been shut
down years ago we've got an interview
coming up today for you about that and
the order doesn't address the legal
conflicts Trump can say bring back
enhanced interrogation or whatever but
there are obviously GLE conflicts here
john mccain does address them more on
that later the legal conflicts being
that these techniques are against the
law and trying to revert to the
bush-cheney era of quote fighting fire
with fire as Donald Trump has been
saying this is stooping to their level
and the backstory if you've forgotten or
just we're not paying attention at the
time is that the Senate voted to ban
torture overwhelmingly in 2015 so uh
they and they did this on the basis that
torture violates both US law and
international law the Geneva Convention
we've got the new Secretary of Defense
mattis who I have no shortage of
criticisms about but he even says no we
don't want torture it doesn't work just
shouldn't be using it Trump on the other
hand Pat feels that torture works he was
asked in that ABC interview yesterday he
feels that it works yeah and it seems as
if general mattis had for a bit of time
convinced Donald Trump against the uses
of waterboarding but I think the point
here is that regardless of whether or
not it actually does work Donald Trump's
going to go through with it anyway
because he thinks that these people
deserve it yeah that's a common thing
we've talked about
this sort of strict father morality on
the right which is you can show the
right that their policy doesn't actually
help to achieve the goals they claim to
want and it often won't really change
their minds because on some level they
believe that the policy reflects what
people deserve and many Republicans
think that of some of these enemy
combatants deserve to be tortured new
CIA director Mike Pompeo seems to be
cooperative says he'd consider using
torture Dianne Feinstein senator from
California said we can't base national
security policies on what we see on
television it has to be grounded in
reality and every day Trump is bringing
us to a new low in a new way probably
worse than Cheney on this issue and
yesterday we had the story about how
yeah we can blame and judge Trump voters
for their votes here is another way in
which whatever the reason you ultimately
voted for Trump whatever that reason was
this is the end result this is what
we're seeing and john mccain is not
taking any of it Republican Arizona
Senator John McCain sent out a tweet
about yes about this exact issue
yesterday where he said
POTUS can sign whatever executive orders
he likes but the law is the law we're
not bringing back torture and you know
things have shifted radically when the
guy I never would have voted for in the
2008 election for president is the voice
of reason within his own party some
people saying should we start talking
about impeachment if this goes far
enough especially the torture issue and
legal implications
that's an uphill battle that is a really
uphill battle especially because you
need Congress to be involved in those
impeachment proceedings a House and
Senate again controlled by Republicans
but which is the party of the president
in the White House that's a real uphill
battle really bringing us back to some
pretty dark times in recent American
foreign policy history everyday it's
amazing how much destruction Donald
Trump is leaving in his wake today's
show is made possible in part by blue
apron blue apron is working to have a
smaller impact on the community their
seafood is sourced sustainably
understand
developed in partnership with the
Monterey Bay Aquarium Seafood Watch the
beef is raised humanely chickens or
free-range regenerative farming
practices are used for produce and blue
apron can be delivered to 99% of the
continental United States and 99.5
percent of food deserts and the I I know
I mentioned this every time I love that
blue apron ships you the exact amount of
each ingredient required for a recipe
and you don't throw food out you don't
end up with half a container of cream
left over you don't end up with two
green onions that now you don't know
what to do with and we also know that
cooking together helps build strong
family bonds and research shows that
blue apron families cook together nearly
three times more often some of the meals
available this month spaghetti squash
and marinara with mushrooms and garlic
knots and spicy shrimp and Korean rice
cakes with cabbage check out this week's
menu and get your first 3 meals for free
with free shipping by going to blue
apron comm slash Pakman you will love
how good it feels and tastes to create
great home-cooked meals with group blue
apron don't wait blue apron dot-com
slash Pakman